Donald Trump und Kim Jong und der
US-Präsident und der Nordkorea Diktator
die Treffen der beiden die waren ein
Tabubruch der mächtigste Mann der Welt
begibt sich auf Augenhöhe mit dem Irren
Nordkorea Diktator und startet mit ihm
dann auch noch eine Brieffreundschaft
eine politische Sensation 27 Briefe
Folgen zwischen Trump und Kim aber was
bitteschön stand da drin jetzt gibt's
einen ersten Einblick darüber sprechen
will mit unserem us-korrespondenten
Herbert powernebel und Schuld daran
sozusagen ist Bob Woodward die Reporter
Legende mit seinen Tonbändern mit Donald
Trump acht Stunden Gespräche und
plötzlich tiefer Einblicke in seine ja
offenbar echte Männerfreundschaft mit
Kim Jong-un
ja tatsächlich wirklich
schockierende Enthüllungen eigentlich
oder gar nicht so schockieren wenn man
denkt dass sie über Donald Trump Handeln
sind 27 private Donald Trump hat sie war
gezeigt wo dort hat damals für sein Buch
recherchiert und in diesen Briefen hat
er war einfach klar zu sehen wie es wie
eng diese Menschen meiner Freundschaft
war Donald Trump hat das so verglichen
als würde man da auf ein Date gehen
praktisch und eine Frau treffen und
sofort wissen dass hier alles stimmt
also praktisch Liebe auf den ersten
Blick ja Donald Trump hat auch klar
gesagt dass er Kim John für sehr
gerissen und für sehr schlau hält der
hat dazu gesagt dass die dass er damit
der CIA dem eigenen Geheimdienst
widersprechen würde denn die CIA würde
Kim Jon um eher für dämlich erhalten all
das sorgt natürlich für gehörige
Aufregung lieber auf den ersten Blick
wie Donald Trump das schildert sein
Verhältnis seine Offenbach
Männerfreundschaft mit Kim Jong und wie
finden die Amerikaner dass wir finden
dass die Trump Anhänger bei denen mit
solchen Aussagen
ja die Anhänger von Donald Trump sagen
natürlich dass es gut wäre wenn man mit
jedem redet auch mit Diktatoren wie eben
Kim jong- und auf der anderen Seite hier
im polarisierten Amerika sagen natürlich
die Kritiker von Donald Trump dass das
völlig überzogen war und auch eine
Verherrlichung der
eines Diktators wäre mehr oder weniger
und sie sagen auch auch wenn Donald
Trump sich immer wieder gepostet hat
dass die Beziehungen besser geworden
werden zwischen Nordkorea und den USA
sagen seine Kritiker das Nordkorea
natürlich weiter an seinem Atomprogramm
gearbeitet hat auch wenn es weniger
Tests und eben hauptsächlich Atomtest
gegeben hat während der Zeit von Donald
Trump also das alles enthüllen jetzt
diese Tonbänder die in dem neuen
audiobook von Bob Woodward dieser
Reporter Legende dann zu hören sind darf
sich Kim Jong Uni jetzt auf einen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten Trump freuen
ja auch bei diesem Thema könnte es in
den nächsten wochenentwicklungen geben
natürlich zuerst finden in den USA in
Anfang November die wichtigen Kongress
Zwischenwahlen statt hier hoffen die
Republikaner dass sie im Kongress ihre
Mehrheit die Mehrheit zurückerobern
können von den Demokraten und danach
wird damit gerechnet dass Donald Trump
seine nächste Kandidatur offiziell
machen würde ob er dann Chancen hat im
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2024 wird man
sehen ja zuerst muss ja auch einen
wachsenden Widerstand in seiner eigenen
Partei überwinden es gibt hier mehr und
mehr Leute bei den Republikanern die
sagen dass Donald Trump vielleicht doch
nicht der Kandidat sein sollte im Jahr
2024 aber das letzte Wort haben hier
natürlich die Wähler und besonders die
Republikaner republikanischen
Parteimitglieder danke an unseren
us-korrespondenten und danke an Herbert
Bauer Nebel
[Musik]